let's go brass and my name is and
welcome to so I added all my thumbnails
every single day and every once in a
while I come across how do I put it some
special stock images so I thought we're
gonna recreate some of those on the
Fridays with PewDiePie show
let's do terrified hamburgers Ellen
DeGeneres stick Sakura tip renews fresh
carrots in the morning make me happy is
that right my best friend electricity
plug your knife Rider
I love carrots - and can I smell some
get off happy but get a girl I'm angry
melon loving man Oh I'm alone please say
you always loved me you made me the
happiest man alive come here angry
bananaphone men what are you [ __ ]
telling me there's no bananas are you
[ __ ] bananas shitty class lady foot
hand man what the [ __ ]
my heart's the feet now I can't fist me
daddy
uh-huh that I'm [ __ ] it what I call
this yeah and you like them legs baby
all right friends wasn't that just
amazing leave a like if you think I
should be the next stock image top model
if that even is a thing and let me know
if you want to see more videos like
these that's all for this week I hope
you bros enjoyed and as always thank you
so much for watching my videos and
showing your support browse it really
means a lot to me so as always we're
gonna end it with the brofist stay
awesome bros